one two one two three
[Music]
Wow guys welcome back to another episode
of corridor cast I probably just blew
out the recording of that so I'm going
to talk a little quieter but wow we got
an amazing guest today one of our
dearest friends
the only Sun when the sun is shining the
only Sun when the Sun ain't shining and
he's just shining all the time
Brett driver what's going on buddy
what's going on son joining us we got
Clint alright what's up guys we got
Nicholas wrong it's up and of course
Christian on the on the recordings as
always he's going amazing by the way
dude ray Christian Brett I am so happy
to have you sit and write like six feet
from me right now son yeah there'll be
to be here six feet from you son
dude only six feet though because son
it's been a long time and I've also
known you for a very long time I just
wanna get right into it with a Christmas
story one of my favorite Brett song
stories it happened on it was New Year's
we were having a good old time at our
friend devons house you know as you do
on New Year's you know the whole family
was there friends and family alike and
it was kind of you it was that time you
know the clock struck midnight everyone
said three two one
Happy New Year and there's those like
annoying little whistle things little
blow with the blowers and we started
lighting these fireworks and not just
your normal everyday firework these were
some heavy-duty fireworks you know
you'll hear them three neighborhoods
four neighborhoods down and yeah so
we're probably five minutes into it and
then all of a sudden like we we all
noticed there's probably twenty five of
us we all notice at the same time like
wait is that a fire and sure enough the
lawn had caught on fire probably like 40
feet down the driveway and you know of
everyone there you know like you know
what are you doing when there's a fire
stop drop and roll yeah you know like
you get the you get the bucket of water
you get the facts here sure well Brett
Brett acted fast you know and he said
not today mr. fire and he
sprint it out down the driveway and I
just remember seen in these tiny tiny
little body because it's like so far
away any any smaller Beckmann leaped
into the air and just body slammed the
fire out and everyone lost their minds
I'm just clapping and like really yes he
did
it was a you guy thing you guys started
this fire yeah I mean you know we were
setting off fireworks you know okay and
then and then you you need it if it had
so had Bret not been there then you
probably be dead
that's like a Medal of Honor movie right
there I think you just probably can you
take us through the logistics of bodies
having a fire Brad like what is from
your perspective I just thought like
Clint said you have to act quick in
these situations if something does not
happen like the it would have it
would've been bad for their lawn number
one you got forbidden one yeah god
forbid the lawn got burned grass let
your body go that yeah I can't you can't
you know what that happen no absolutely
not
I mean yeah Brad I think that's what we
all appreciate about you one of the
things is that you know you're the type
of person who acts on stuff and gets it
done a very hard worker dedicated
definitely well very very dedicated dude
there's so much to get into there's so
many stories I was trying to like we
were sitting here writing down all these
stories and there's just too many of
them and I'm sure some will come up as
we go but um so I guess Brett Brett
where do you think you got that got
lengua that that personality about
yourself you know your ear you're out of
anybody that we know out of all the
corridor crew what have you are our
extended network of friends and family
you know you you definitely fall in
there as somebody who would be willing
to go the extra mile for somebody else
or you'd be willing to you know put your
put your put yourself on the line for
somebody else what do you think you got
that growing up or was it that's a
question I got guests just growing up in
Georgia I guess I mean it's like my
grandfather probably was a huge
influence on
me with that it's just he's a very
creative person he used a lot his voice
a lot and he just he just cared about
people you know not just everywhere I
went with him he just I don't know there
was a genuine respect about the way he
treated people I don't know I just I
just noticed very quick it just it just
like people stay up and you know I deal
with my own issues but yeah I just I
guess that's where it comes from is just
wanting people to be happy you know
yeah and just you know just that
servanthood of caring about what's being
produced you know if you might as well
do it a hundred percent if something
works is worth doing I mean we also we
also grew up going to church too right
yeah we did you know I think kind of
raised in to church honestly was like a
very fire and brimstone type of
atmosphere like screaming at you kind of
thing yeah yeah definitely that kind of
way and I just very young age I don't
know I I have my own beliefs about
things we won't get into obviously but
yeah I guess from very young age or just
notice that something was kind of off
with that mentality is just mm-hmm I
don't know I think there's a way of
loving people and caring about people
without you know that's a whole
different thing ya know for sure so you
guys both grew up in Georgia right no
you grew up here in California or no no
Chino and then you moved to Georgia I
did yeah I moved I moved freshman year
of high school to to Canton Georgia so I
considered a second home I still like my
parents are still there and I still go
back every every year for Christmas so I
I considered part of it part of me was
raised there but Brett you were born in
in Georgia right yeah yeah I was born in
a tiny little town like a few hours blue
Atlanta but um yeah really small town I
was always really big into art into I
was always a very quiet kid and really
know how to express myself too much so
like making films my dad was huge
influence in just the way of picking up
a camera oh really
yeah yeah my it's it's a weird situation
to talk about them like my experience my
dad was like always behind the camera
was a kid so like every birthday every
soccer game everything that I've ever
done
literally like film which is a little
weird but I mean got me into picking up
a camera at a very young age and you
know like really caring about how like
telling stories and things like that
very cool so as somebody who as somebody
who you know grew up shy I guess what
where did you make the I guess mental
transition from that to the more
extroverted type that you need to put on
when you're like on a camera or when
you're in a film or what have you
where were you where did you make that
mental shift and then like you know it
was honestly Jake it was probably like
because Clinton we moved here in 2011
and I was here for a few years and then
my my grandparents started going
downhill and they both developed
Alzheimer's disease and things like that
so I moved back I kind of looked after
them for a bit and I guess it was that
point where like I wasn't doing much
filming at all and I was just living at
my grandparents house I'm just taking
care of them and I was just I don't know
it was in a really kind of dark place
for a while and I'd always cared about
acting it was something that I've always
desired to do I think I got into acting
to just be more comfortable with myself
and to learn how to you know communicate
well and things like that so yeah acting
was honestly therapy was a lot of
therapy so I would travel like two hours
to Atlanta every Tuesday and that one
day a week was like my therapy to go
into and just I don't know acting class
was cool because you go in there and
it's like everyone wants to just be
better at being good to each other you
know and being authentic and yeah I
think that was the kind of the shift
they kind of wanted me to you know be
more outgoing and caring about people
more but still tough I deal with you
know a lot of anxiety constantly so yeah
we all do for sure yeah how do you deal
with acting do you just like say like
put it aside and just like deeper I was
telling Jake and Christian you know it's
like this is the most uncomfortable just
talking about myself I hate I hate
I hate it it's like it's so freeing when
you can get like something on paper and
you can learn these words and then you
can kind of create a character and then
you're free to do it you know no one
expects you to be Brett driver no one
expects you to be that person this is
like you can kind of not care about
being someone else and mm-hmm
this is like zero zero expectations some
ways yeah
I try to be Brett driver when I wake up
every day I'm like you son what would
the son do Brett Brett will text me in
the morning sometimes and what is it
says uh it's a brand-new day a bracelet
Jake says what would the son do hey
let's go back here so you you met Clint
in Georgia obviously mm-hmm we met let's
go coastal cuz we've gotten a lot of
requests for Brett for you on the
podcast oh yeah and and I want to answer
some of these questions that people have
commented like hey we oftentimes it's
like hey we're what's Brett up to what's
Brett's involvement with corridor like
how did you guys all meet so take us
through that okay Clint so did you let's
see okay um I was like 2008 two dozen
eight nine dozen nine yeah so I met
Brett on actually on the Indy mogul
YouTube channel I was a huge fan of any
mogul with Eric Beck when he was doing
it way back in the day and they had a
show I think it's called back it was
backyard effects or it was uh it was
like a user-submitted episode where you
know you submit your visual effect and
they'll take the best ones and they'll
compile them and put them at the end the
end of the month
boom you know all of these all these
guys and my my my clip got chosen so of
course I was like this is awesome I'm
watching the episode and I see this clip
of this dude like with no legs and he's
like it's like world war ii Saving
Private Ryan his legs got blown off and
he's all like blood coming out
everywhere and he's screaming uh and and
that was Brett's clip and I'm like what
a hack I was like dude that's so crazy
how it like cuz I was into making World
War two
films and like those gas masks
apocalyptic films like we'll get into
all that stuff but that's how I met
Brett I looked up at his profile said
he's from Atlanta and I just sent him a
message immediately and like I don't
know we got together like the next week
or the next week I drew it to where you
were nantan and then we shot a little
something scared a woman out of her mind
with Clint was burning his gas mask 50
now like just in the middle where people
were jogging is this nice little creek
bed yeah full military getup and yeah we
shot a little something and yeah when I
met you guys when I met you guys I
thought you guys have been friends since
like boyhood I mean it feels that way it
does yeah no yeah we but we've known
each other for a while for sure we moved
to California together I met you around
that time when we were making yeah yeah
you to be like 2009 or 10 yeah we had
made this three part mini feature it was
super low be like free ladies we we all
had jobs and everything else yeah so I
was making I like I think all of 2008
and 2009 I was making this like
post-apocalyptic film as you do yeah
horse doesn't do that and you know I
just filmed like this awesome thing it
put out this trailer you know it was
like I was getting my final edit
together and I released the trailer and
basically it's like you know you dress
up your friends and the the surplus
military gear that you have in a gas
mask of course and you find you know
your local abandoned military building
and you go film a movie yeah you know
and I was I put this out I'm like Dan
this is gonna be so cool the next day I
see Bret's film the free lens I think it
was the trailer for that and like I see
it and it's it's like the same thing
it's like sepia tone color grade son and
five aspect ratios one guy in the midst
of it all shot beautifully as well
super beautifully and just like a lot of
atmosphere and I was like dude I'm
either gonna have to go find this guy
and burn down so yeah man I mean we kind
of had that in common from just like our
whole aesthetic and filmmaking uh I
guess what what interested us you know
we met through that yeah I'm in Racine
Horlick Hollow
and yeah it was like so identical and it
wasn't cool like it was these are how
like a lot of my best friends came par
it was just like my chance on on YouTube
you know which is the strangest thing
yeah what what is it with the
post-apocalyptic thing like if I don't
if okay you got to give me two
inspirations from from stuff you're into
that inspired you to be into
post-apocalyptic shorts yeah two things
days later okay it was really a big one
okay and then oh man what was the other
one for Hollow it's hard to say there
was a little bit of behind enemy lines
in there probably but yeah I mean bookie
lied to ya
what about you it was definitely a Book
of Eli oh yeah in the road for me
Saving Private Ryan of course 28 days
later behind enemy lines no doubt and
then like Silent Hill 2 actually yeah it
was like a huge inspiration just like
wandering around abandoned places with
eerie music and fog like that's so ah
it's just the best
I came freaks me out so much you showed
me that game for the first time like
yeah man that's even the original ones
freaky my real question the important
question is what what's your favorite
type of gas masks you know do you like
the one with the two filters I like the
one with the you know the Russian one I
like so you want to filters one there's
none can fail on you and you can still
survive
it's a relevant question it's the bulky
one it's all about the bulky one with
like you know like the filters like the
ones that don't they pop out but they're
like right in here you know sick Oh half
life that was no of course
dude like the guys like combine we all
have our own like like version of gas
masks soldier bad guys in each one of
our fingers like you had yours like you
had like the camera guy's ears I had
camo and gas masks mine were like just
like the combine they had black clothing
with gas masks Clint came out for one I
mean you were the soldier at in the hall
you memorable with a huge gun yeah that
hotel they like torch down was one
amazing thing yeah it was just we had so
access to so many abandoned locations in
Georgia there's an abundance of them I
think that's why it's just like we were
like what can we what can we do with you
know the resources we have you had that
awesome mill yeah do which we filmed
also post-apocalyptic gives you access
to all these other like genres within it
you know you've got action you've got
drama you've got mystery you know yeah
you can go in all these different
directions and so you only need one
camera
you only need one character and then you
call your buddies for like the couple
other scenes that you need to have the
Horde or you know whatever and all of a
sudden you have this also it removes it
from the regular world because the first
thing you want to do when you pick up a
camera is like like well I don't want to
film the real world that's that's what
I've been living in the whole point of
like telling stories to tell a different
story that they on world so and then you
have all the yeah you have all the
abandoned buildings dude no for sure it
just has so much texture I know man and
beautiful yeah I'm really grateful that
we all down the gas masks and went out
made those movies because yeah lifelong
friends then the first time I actually
met Brett face-to-face was we'd met
another filmmaker Keith Potter he
thought her and he's over
Toronto and we met on Facebook and we
like wrote a film together through the
internet and then Keith and I flew at
the tiny little town yeah that's your
tiny town and uh yeah it was kind of
like that was the first time I'd ever
left the a that's the first time I'd
ever been to the south like at all first
time I'd ever met you in real life and
the first time I'd ever like
collaborated on a film with two other
people yeah it was awesome I'd pick you
up from the airport I remember we would
like literally we're shooting the next
day and we just went straight to
Goodwill yeah and then I remember you
were supposed to film your Killzone
extraction piece right yeah that same
week same week and I was so cuz I'm like
oh yeah I'm gonna get to be like help
out with like Punishers film oh sweet
but it was too snowy I know cuz I
couldn't make it down it's like a two
and a half hour drive and I was gonna be
slippin slidin on me place that was the
case it was snowing yeah it was ice
Stormers actually yeah we got we I mean
it kind of benefited us cuz it looked
really cool for our phone oh heck yeah
we ended up shooting yeah though I mean
this just short takes place over like
what two weeks or something so it's like
you have yeah you went from like a sunny
day it's like a rainy night into the
snowy like it was so you guys got so
lucky that's the best I think it's what
makes it to is just the the change in
season yeah that look of it just the
feeling of like a team effort was so
nice they're like we you know all the
actors who flew out there all local
Georgia actors exhale we had casted yeah
everything was done just every we were
all in different places and just making
some food somehow I can just eat and
chicken nuggets every night let's just
get some chicken so eventually Nik Hugh
and Brett were roommates
well yeah first Brett was roommates with
yeah we first yeah we know yeah let's
yeah so in the studio yeah we're getting
all out of order here
that was a you moved here yeah we at
Clinton I well actually you'd moved here
a little bit before me yeah this was in
2011 eleven thousand eleven I came back
for Christmas
hmm and then we drove out together right
yeah packed my car and then what we
didn't sleep at all I don't know we
didn't sleep at all that was the worst
experience of dude it was so bad like 36
hours straight from Georgia to Los
Angeles and it was asleep no no dude it
was so bad oh dude no offense no offense
Jake but driving through Texas was just
Oh music son 24 hours of just nothing he
was wrong no sleep and here's the thing
too is like we got the point we were
just so tired you know that's that
feeling you start just getting jittery
yeah we had I think what eight bottles
of eight hour energy we had like the
shots they're just real quick for people
who don't know how big Texas is just
just going across from Houston to El
Paso which is like the short the short
way but if you go from Mexico to
Oklahoma it's even longer but I started
I would Houston the other day and I was
on the 10 and the 10 you know every
state that an interstate enters it
starts with mile one right and so when
you enter El Paso it starts with mile
one and I went to Houston and it was
like eight hundred and forty or
something oh my god
yeah the mile markers were just you know
and that's when I you know that's kind
of depressed sort of settled in you like
eight forty you're like all right yeah
yeah you just not look at signs for a
while eight hundred forty miles an hour
you'll be there in an hour
I mean we're here we're here we're here
quick aside do it yeah me and Nichols
died yeah you want to just break down
that quick story it's just and it's kind
of a tangent
it is Clint Clint hits me up randomly
one night he's like ham I'm going up to
San Francisco real fast cuz this is this
kid literally real fast like for like a
day like a night he's like you want to
come with me because I know you like
World War 2 stuff and this this kid who
knows this guy named Hans that means a
lot of World War 2 memorabilia
dude he own oh my god it was apparently
a bunch of Tanks son a bunch of Tanks
was that Dracula tanks filled the tanks
and half-tracks and like a whole
basement full of World War two like
costumes and stuff but and I'm like heck
yes that sounds awesome you know go up
there so we drove up to Northern
California at we started at like 5:00
p.m. from LA we started later than that
dude yeah we started at like 8:00 p.m.
and we get in Clint's car and we're just
driving at night and night driving and I
don't like it for many reasons but it's
just this is another one of those
reasons this just adds to the reasons we
were playing 20 questions as we were we
were playing too many questions it was
getting pretty intense these questions
they were they're popping off yeah and I
don't know we weren't paying attention
we were taking an access highway to get
from the five freeway over to the 101
freeway I think so you have to cut
across there's some farmland in the
middle of California Genki it goes to
this narrow freeway and Clint I guess
Clint's driving you cued it up you say
to my life yeah I cute a question but
Clint merges over to the left lane with
this highway and we're just speeding
along and I don't remember what the
question was but we were pondering
something awful because yeah I think
either of us were looking ahead of us
and you know like there's a headlight
coming his headlight I'm like alright
it's just a car coming in front of us
and at the very last moment I look over
and I see that the headlight is actually
right in front of us and that we're not
on a two-lane road and you didn't merge
the left lane you merge to the opposite
side yeah and man yeah I just remember
like you said whoa dude whoa I look up
there's one of those quick moments where
I was like
you in the wrong way on a one-way I was
on the opposite side of the road Jake
middle of the night we thought it was a
two-lane highway because we'd been on a
highway which was only relateable lanes
going in the same direction and I guess
we just was lazy now is this was Brett
with you guys no no we were doing aside
we were talking about drives we're on a
kissing cuz I thought you were about to
say that like he was waiting for an
interjection where he enters the story
but in that moment I thought what would
the son do yeah yeah exactly
exactly yeah you're not joining the PI
Red Sea that was a sketchy time I'm glad
we didn't die yeah we didn't at least
sucked
that would have been Jude dude it
would've been over like literally if
that question was a little bit harder
like no more questions no more questions
but that but let's get back let's get
back to the other car ride you guys
driving out yeah California what year is
this you're in Texas 24 hours driving
straight through Texas so we didn't
sleep once and it was miserable but we
finally landed and it was oh man it was
it was great
anything to get out of that car yeah I
think we met up with you that day when
we landed I was kadhi canned
oh my gosh yeah yeah so you guys have
known each other from the filming that
you did at Georgia Nick you guys do Nick
and then you got here and did you
already have spots in the studio cuz
when I met you both you were living in
studio 6 that's yeah it's where we moved
to so we were right behind ya we're
Freddie and Brandon we're at the time I
was like their main problem right yeah
we're Freddie and Jimmy you say live
then they live there
we're back there everyone god I forget
it's really on me so no Freddy and Jimmy
were in three mm-hmm and then but I was
out so I I was living out of this room
with no windows and no door in this
brick wall dude just surrounded by brick
walls how you guys did that dude I was
just faster as Spencer did that room for
like eight years man I know man and that
is props to him though because like you
guys were just sweating dude Brett was
living under the toilet pipes driven
drop it oh man there's some horrible
stories you know what yeah there was one
where I woke up this one morning who
tell you this night you didn't well are
you talking about the sock yes okay the
previous night previous night you were
taking a shower and I was like I'm a
scared Brett so I went in I snuck into
your room and I was holding that's what
cause no I definitely cause it I was so
I snuck in your room and I hiked up my
boxers I was just look I was basically
naked and I was in the corner of the
room with the lights off and I had like
stuck my head on the side of the wall
and I smeared it so I was like you know
some like Silent Hill creature he turns
around nude he turns around and he goes
oh he drops he drops to the ground he's
you made him faint
he nearly immediately dropped to the
ground he doesn't remember it because
it's a blank spot in his brain because
it was so it was so true horrifying but
then Briggs what happened get to that
next morning go for that next all right
whether that happen or not what happened
from your side I I thought it was I
looked over and I tweaked my neck I
thought that was the case he scared so
bad that this is what about anyway I
apparently I woke up the next morning
and I think I had pinched a nerve I
think that was the case but I could not
even move my like no joke I could not
move even like the frack if I did it
would just the most excruciating pain
I've ever felt and I couldn't move I
just called for Clint and I say dude I
can't I can't move
I can't move and it lasted about two
days but the first Clint's intuition is
I need something cold or something give
me a contract pet presser so it was a
hot it's like a hot like a warm-up this
man goes up into the kitchen wraps his
old dirty sock it wasn't mine and I
found in the corner he cooked an old
out-of-date tortilla stuck it in the
sock and then microwave that in the
market microwave did what and it was
just and I thought it would be like you
don't want to put a searing tortilla you
were going for like the rice method yes
he brings this to me and I put it on my
neck I'm like clay what is this and he
goes it's my sock I wrapped a tortilla
in it Mike what did it make your neck
feel better no my heart was in it for
the whole time all right how long did
you guys live back in those caves men
like a year I think just a year really
seems like it was longer it does I
remember visiting you guys and I was
like how do you live here hey like
Freddie and Brandon and like everyone
who's Ben Maller I think was yeah and
then yeah Angie they were all like in
full production all the time dude all
the time yes laughs dude it would be 3
a.m. like we're all back there like you
know trying to keep a normal sleep
schedule
god forbid typings and the loudest
keyboards be skyping Freddie's notorious
typing oh yeah he's still typing right
now yeah but it was definitely there was
definitely a really cool energy you guys
lived there at a really cool time when
things were oh man it was great it
must've been crazy to in that
environment
it's weird so I left where I was because
like I mean Lana's thriving it's means
more or less
picking up a lot but I mean when I had
left there was like nothing going on and
and it seemed like the only people who
were doing stuff were in LA at the time
so yeah it was definitely an interesting
journey yeah yeah I mean that that was
kind of the transition between like
traditional film and digital media as we
know it today and as it continues to
evolve but that that period of like that
that eight year period or so you know
things were kind of everyone was trying
to figure out what to do next because
everyone knew that something was coming
but no one exactly knew how or you know
how to make it work on the production
side and they were Freddy and Brandon in
studio 6 keeping you guys up till 3:00
a.m. with film and God knows what
turning around videos every way because
every week yeah that was yeah it was a
crazy time it was really fun milkman
milkman milkman was so I remember that
night I came down to just the hang you
know yeah I was like yeah hang on then
you're like oh wait well I'm supposed to
be in this Freddy video and turns out it
was milkman and I was just sitting there
watching you know well I had done stuff
in my own stuff it was like you know
cameo pieces I I was growing up where I
was I think I always wanted to act and
do that but that really I I was always
behind the camera I think my just my
dad's involvement with shooting you know
movies I picked up a camera when I was
young and I don't know I still love
shooting I love creating you know
composition was in the camera not
something I miss I've definitely
redirected myself in in some ways but
it's definitely unique man like you
don't see a lot of people who are like I
mean me and Clint both know you
primarily we knew you primarily as a
filmmaker
you don't see a lot of people who are
like really good like this skill like
you have a great visual sense and like
great camera man good
mmm-hmm director and then you're like
well I kind of really just want to act
and so you what you went back to Georgia
for a couple of years right I did yeah
yeah for just for my grandparents yeah
yeah and that was yeah for sure now
that's kind of when you decided I think
that was kind of like I said nothing was
really going on in Georgia and like you
know it's such a no one's really doing
their own thing the biggest things were
were obviously TV shows and I did stand
in work for a few shows damn Vampire
Diaries I worked on four is that where
you learned how to stunt fall no at this
time I think I think through
skateboarding that was kind of the whole
thing
skateboarding probably really got me
into making movies too it's just you
know we were all we would always make
you know skate videos and things like
that
but yeah I think just learning
skateboarding you have to if you're
hitting rails or anything like that you
just have to you know know when you're
gonna eat it and just hope to roll out
of it I don't I don't classify anything
I do as stunt man I think it's just
hopefully not hurting yourself like I'm
more like do it and hope I don't hurt
myself exactly I can you know less it's
like a like tiny guns you know like that
was horrible obviously I had you know I
mean totally but you know things like
that I just you know learning how to
recover out of something if something
goes bad you know I think yeah worrying
is a good teacher of that video where
there's a video on the same and you
coach at a quarter crew channel where
it's like you showing us how to likes
don't fall oh you're so funny dude and
then like you did us don't fall into the
wall and freaking like oh man that's a
good video you guys should go watch that
video for the memories or the time the
time like what what gets me is the one
where you leave Ren's driveway and you
open this you go to open the gate but
the gate is totally like falls apart on
you and you like stumble like that's the
that is the freakin funniest visual gag
to me
it was like it was it was genuine it
actually happened Larry I was up that
was so yeah I was working in the gym in
the bar at that point and I was I'd
stayed up all night and then thought we
had a kickflip in 24 hours so when did
you when did you start living with Nick
was that when you moved back
that was when I moved back yeah so after
you know it got the point where cuz he
lived with Clint first though in the
house right you guys yeah we live for
another leg custody in a year to
Pasadena with with at the time Maxum man
action Amanda were there as well yeah
that was a fun house you guys used to
have parties parties were awesome cuz
everybody came over and it was good yeah
hangout
rock climbing the walls mm-hmm yeah but
that was like two years right and then
years you moved in with Nick wasn't that
was well no nobody back that's you you
and I landed back yeah that was my
grandparents time and then um yeah I'd
spent I think almost two and a half
years they're not doing a whole lot of
anything actually I wasn't doing much
filming I wasn't doing anything like I
was just like literally one day a week I
would go to the acting class and like I
said that was really where the probably
my passion and that was my courage to to
try to go into acting cuz I've always
wanted to do it and obviously video
games and my grandfather was you know he
was a huge he loved he loved movies he
loved actors he was a huge fan of Elvis
James Dean Marlon Brando so like I was
watching these films I was a kid and
it's like yeah that's something that I
always intrigued me but was so against
the grain of me he's like I'm so very
you know not the most spoken person and
I so it's just like yeah I would took a
lot of courage to kind of go into the
class like I drove two hours to get
there and just sat in the parking lot
debating if I wanted to even go in yeah
it was terrifying yeah I met a lot of
awesome people there and it was just it
was it was an amazing experience and
definitely the the time that I needed to
get back to myself you know because then
so then you you came back up to LA or
back over
and then you live which is even scarier
the second time the first time what were
the circumstances of the second time was
it just you the point where I was just I
didn't I never wanted to leave LA to be
honestly was something there I just kind
of needed to do because there's a lot of
my my dad and my dad's parents and
everything was a lot of my dad my mom
was still working but no it was it was
it was it was just a very isolating time
for sure yeah yeah and then we I think
he moved back out to LA and then
eventually you were looking for a room
and so was I with my other roommate
currently and yeah we found a really
good cheap place in Koreatown and yeah
yeah I was haunted it was pretty good
yeah with Zach for a little while I went
you know he was living in Reseda for a
while so I moved there for bed and that
was kind of that was when I gave you a
shout Jake see if you got anything else
so that was around the same time yeah
and then we were looking for a place
closer to LA yeah I'm still there but
yeah you moved what like last year late
last year for like two years right good
Tom good living so overall I mean so
it's 2020 now and you've been you know
you've come out to LA as of nine years
ago you know you went back and forth a
bit out of all this time I guess like
what have you learned about yourself and
and about how you apply that to what you
do now since moving since moving out
there you mean creatively or just in
life in general like life in general but
then you know after that I guess
creatively hmm email I'm sorry
like you mean like what did I learn back
in Georgia wanted to come back here to
apply or no like you've been you know
and this is how old are you now I'm 33
yeah so it's been so when you came out
you were what 22 23 - yeah
- mm-hmm so as you've gone through this
time now out here in the city you know I
guess how have you evolved as a person
how have you
oh wow yeah okay well I'm you know I'm
from a very small town I don't know a
lot of a lot of the town that I'm
interested it's very stuck in the 1940s
you know and I just know that I just
wanted to always you know see the world
and understand other people's
perspectives you know and in yeah I
guess I guess that's the biggest thing
did you did you have expectations of
success when you moved out here or like
of what you thought life would be like
in LA or were you just kind of like
let's just see what happens and if you
did or if you didn't have they changed
like you have those expectations with
all it was definitely a lot of you know
where did you I guess where did you see
yourself like going like by moving to LA
did you want to I guess like be a
director or like being I mean what was
like you're a patient I'm early I've
always loved working with actors like I
really love that that's that's
ultimately the love of it and I love I
love writing I love words I don't know I
think there's so much power in acting I
think there's so much power and
filmmaker I don't know every creative
endeavor like so you're working on
you're working on a writing endeavor now
currently aren't you um I I'm a writers
assistant for a show but because of
because of that opportunity it's only
increased my love for writing so yeah
I'm spending a lot of time writing my
own stuff for sure so what is that on
the current gig and then and then how do
you translate that into your own work
mmm I think because I'm having to look
at scripts every day and you know for
for this specific one is an animated TV
show that my buddies is is co co-creator
of but that is just you know every
single day you're getting a different
script and it's 13 episodes of teeth of
an you know TV show there's it's not
like live-action or anything else where
you get one script and that's what I'm
used to them used to having one script
to go off
and this you're getting so many
iterations of scripts it's just based
off one thing from you know network
notes and things like that that they're
having to change and it's for my job
it's just just being so focused on what
changes are done because every week
you're having to you know send line you
know record sheets to actors and what
they need to do and if line changes you
know and they get the stuff back it's
just so everything just requires just a
very careful eye so you have to have a
hyper focus on the details of writing
I'm not necessarily writing just the
deep just what's being written I'm not
my responsibility is not to write the
show my responsibility is taking the
scripts and just you know whatever
changes are happening things like that
but they're communicated to the CEO who
need to know the exact I explained it to
me it was like there's all these there's
like this whole staff this whole board
of writers right like and every change
they make they send to you to put in the
master script is that how it works
well David and Nolan are the ones who
were writing the show so they like I
said they they'll they'll make a draft
and you know constantly things or you
know they'll get notes from network and
things like that this is final space by
the way on TBS final space yeah third
season right third season awesome
awesome
it's and it's got a great cast you know
Ashley birch and there's a lot of oh
really
really yeah yeah yeah there's there's so
many cool like I don't know this is I
think just loving videogames you know
that was something that I've just always
wanted to do yeah and just you know
being around actors it's it's it's kind
of it's very nice you know it's just
learning the process and in taking my
own goals what my goals are
yeah and they're kind of aligning here
because I'm able to see what other
actors are doing and how they're you
know what they're doing too because oh
sorry no I was just gonna ask like is
there any so you're you're dealing with
all these like really like these career
professional top of their game writers
on the show right I mean I'm not dealing
with obviously like I mean but you're
like you're seeing how they work and
like you're having to like be part of
that workflow what can you take from
that because it is a network animation
so right so that's obviously different
from like live-action and stuff that
like we usually make yeah but is there
anything you can take from that like as
a writer like has there been any like
process or like I think I mean just
seeing the the amount of I'm so used to
just like getting down on myself when
you're writing some things like oh this
shouldn't be like this it shouldn't be
like this totally and then you get so
jaded about that one part that you never
finish it Oh 100% so that's just like
yeah you see like okay they're putting
out so many drafts every week it's like
okay we'll finish a draft and then from
there I can always go back and tweak
things and things like that the most
important part is just if you have an
idea finish it you know and I've got I'm
one to speak you know just like I've got
projects that I never finished or things
failed but man I look back I'm just like
man I've I learned the most from things
that went wrong I didn't really learn
much from things that went right so you
know like the same concept applies to
multiple aspects of filmmaking I think
you know like with editing I've been
doing more and more editing especially
since I moved out here and one of the
things that I have been applying is is
the same like idea which is just if you
find yourself in a point and an edit
that you feel like it's not working just
get the idea
mapped out and then keep going you know
because you can you're if you don't get
through it and at least get a draft of
it down then you can never make
adjustments you can never make
improvements to it and you can ever see
how it fits in with the overall piece so
it's the same I think that's the same
with everything in life like it released
when it comes to like building something
it's the same with 3d modeling you know
I usually I'll start with a block out if
I'm modeling something I'll block it out
with just like cubes and see is this the
shape I want and then from there and
once you see that the shape works then
you go in and detail it the same of the
script and like the heart to me when
writing the hardest part is getting the
v1 out but once you have the v1 then
it's like oh okay great then now we can
now I can yeah I can see the hard work
has been done and then you can tweak
tweak tweak yeah
but yeah it must be crazy just watching
these these professionals just to Frank
out V ones and V 2 is like 11 yeah it's
very inspiring you know it's like is you
know it just makes me realize to that
you know yeah there's always something
to fix and there's always something that
you can refine and no ideas ever
complete really have you ever been
surprised like guys why are you like why
do you keep writing this like it's
already really good like yeah I have
yeah cuz a lot like honestly like
they're really good at writing and but
the same time when they put out another
draft it's like okay yeah I see well
yeah yeah it's just it's it's something
that they always like pinpoint is its
they're always thinking about what
happened last season okay that happened
that this would be a good thing to - and
it - with fans you know fans know better
than the creators most the time of what
they want to see so I think they really
really do listen they're fans a lot it's
really good yeah because everything that
they've done is just it's amazing in
animation such a different beasts that
I'm completely I'm in a completely new
element with obviously but I'm thankful
to just like I said earlier just serve
you know and in to learn through serving
is yeah there's no better way so I just
I hope I'm doing a good job with what
I'm you know my required tasks the
writers assistant and yeah I just
it's definitely built that muscle of
starting to write again and keep that
discipline for sure so what's next for
you man I mean do you want to take some
of this and go out and do another piece
after this another video I've got
something that I uh it's it's been on my
heart for a while just going back to my
grandparents condition like I've been
writing a piece for a palette like past
three years or so kind of it's not based
on my life but there's a lot of things
that I think solve issues behind that
specific disease and art talk to me talk
about which is this Alzheimer's in
general so there's the thing that I'm
writing is very it's kind of a personal
project but yeah I think there's a I
think I always think about what can i
what can I do to help someone else and
the ways are a story that might convey
someone else that's going through
something in a dark time what are some
of those elements I guess of Alzheimer's
that
that you're trying to get out in that um
I guess how how much it could divide
family like I mean it's it's it's
interesting because like you look at the
people the you know my grandparents say
they were never really truly if you go
through some really difficult parts of
them forgetting who they are and
forgetting who you are but it's it's
always straining on more of the people
who were taking care of them and the
people's family like my grandparents
were always just very peaceful you know
like even in that condition they're
peaceful even though that sometimes they
wouldn't know what's going on which is
always very hurtful for our immediate
family and that caring process and it
was very straining you know figuring out
because it almost feels like you're
you're losing your mind with them in a
lot of ways yeah you took on a lot of
brunt of that caretaking that's how you
both of them had it so it was almost
like taking care of children Wow so as
somebody who's gone through that process
and what can you have for it do you have
anything that you've learned any advice
that you can offer to somebody else that
might be experiencing that um it's it's
tough because it feels like I said it
feels like the end of the world when
you're going through it but she's got to
know that you know this too shall pass
you know it's it's a tattoo that's the
only tattoo that I've got and it was
just kind of when I moved back to LA I
just wanted something to remember that
time it was still in that same year yeah
this too shall pass you know just you
got to know that's not the end and it
sucks that he said oh no it's the worst
I think it's personally the worst
disease and yeah just cuz they don't
mean obviously I was affected me my
grandparents were affected by it but no
I just I think the biggest thing is you
know no one has no one that no one is
certain no one has promised tomorrow so
the biggest thing is just you know
loving time that you have with the
people that you love
you just got the point where I felt like
I was at the end of my road and I wasn't
I don't know I hadn't make another move
so the biggest thing for me is the
biggest thing was for me was to get my
parents pieces like I felt like I was
abandoning my grandparents a long way by
coming back to LA
mmm no I'm grateful for that time that I
had with them and uh yeah it's uh
definitely the time that I needed to go
back to learn something about myself for
sure yeah that's tough you know you know
you never plan it but at the same time
you know that as creators I think in the
process of those things of the things
that hit you in life that you don't plan
sometimes that when you learn the most
and oftentimes when afterwards you can
center yourself on a specific goal that
you might not have otherwise had prior
to that experience yeah Jake yeah since
first since we're heavier I know yeah I
know
both of your parents passed right yep
yep in a in a two year period I lost I
lost both my parents 2013 and 2015
did you feel after that moment that like
you had to that you had to push harder
and do something for them and like kind
of as a way to move on but also kind of
like dedicating a next big push to them
or something like did you feel that way
uh yeah I think so I heard I don't know
if Scott Van Pelt from ESPN said this
but he said a man who loses their their
father early spends the rest of their
life trying to I guess live up to what
they wanted you to be and I think the
thing that hit me more so than anything
through that experience was I realized
you know very clearly and obviously for
the very first time that well just to
preface this you know I set off on my
own when I was 18 and I had been kind of
independent for many years but very
clearly and obviously after that point I
realized that there was no
fall back of any kind you know ask 28 I
think 27 yeah 20 says 2015 so I was 28
yeah and I realized that you know there
was that that anything that I had to do
required me to you know set all my setup
set myself up for that success and I
always felt like that because they
always taught me that but yeah I guess
you know there's like a renew there at
least for me there was a renewed sense
of passion and I guess urgency to to to
live up to some of these not necessarily
what their dreams were for me but for
what I for what my dreams were for
myself yeah and then like you said Brett
I mean you're never guaranteed in second
day and like you're talking about your
grandfather earlier when we started and
just saying how there's always this idea
of treating people with respect because
you don't know what you don't know where
they came from you don't know what they
what they're going through you don't
know what they're doing what they've
done for others etc and just keeping
that in the back of your head you know
when you're going throughout your day
and and and trying to think less of of
yourself and and more of you know who
you're who you're interacting with yeah
it's tough it's definitely a tough
challenge especially now you know but
yeah it's something yeah it's a good
moral to have a good like grounding
value to have you know think of others
don't always assume the worst of people
yeah yeah super boys and you know Dale
Carnegie has a good book I resisted
reading it for the longest you good ones
but he's got how to win friends and
influence people and I resisted reading
it for the longest time just solely
based on that title because I'm not the
type of person that wants to win friends
and influence people but the heart of it
is
is is quite the opposite of that at the
end of it it's it's people will will
listen people will wine or interact with
you and respond to you if you are
generally interested in them and that's
you know kind of the message of the book
and I don't know it's just a good take
on on that whole idea absolutely I feel
like I need to reread that one man
that's a good good book it is it is it's
very helpful and it also gives you a
clarity I think you know especially with
everything that's going on in like the
world today you know the last few months
and everything it's like it can often
feel like you know you're going crazy
right alongside somebody else but a lot
of times you know you take that step
back you think about you think about
others and a lot of times that that that
break-in mentality can set you straight
and put you where you need to be because
typically they're mean there's something
there's I think things typically happen
when there's something to learn and
you're out you're in an aspect your life
or in a season your life you know things
happen I I try to believe that just
because I mean it keeps your mind out of
a dark situation it might arise but yeah
I think there is always something to
take away and you know oh yeah
implement the things that the people we
love the most of have taught us dude
well that's why we love you son I love
y'all so that's what everybody's a son
son yeah son so I know we just want you
gonna ask me where that come no no I
have a couple things I want to ask you
about regarding that son cuz Brett
driver here is one of the only humans I
know who has his own catchphrase and I'm
not I mean a catchphrase it's not just a
saying
I don't know if it's my catchphrase it's
definitely not I'm pretty sure that we
started saying it more other people that
we did not know started using it more
maybe was just like I don't think I'm
the first person to say I think it's
just like I got it from you you are like
there's like a digital statue of
somewhere with son edged at the base of
it like he was
face of Sun like there's been like old
Southern gentleman saying it for
generations but you're like that's like
you're bringing it into the news even so
much that there's like one of the most
successful VR video games here the
character and that and we have that and
I wanted to ask you about bone works
did you ever see yourself being a video
game character and like what went
through what was your thought process
when Brandon asked you to I guess what
did he ask you was that Jake or do you
just feel like your whole life is a
video no I mean it's it's it's it's
still like very hum honestly it's it's
still very humbling it's my whole life
I've loved video games I think that's
ultimately why I wanted to tell stories
because it's my dad and I we we didn't
really get along with too many things
but games are that one thing that we
really really yeah the games like I
would grew up on the Atari and
everything else and I don't know I think
the games have always been a part of my
life but no it's it's when Brandon came
to me about it it was like oh okay
that's that's awesome yeah I mean
granion I had to say son a million times
it was you know it's so you seem
reluctant about that though is that is
his son something that you try to I mean
we all think it's hilarious and it's
just kind of like an inside joke right
like I could see how that could not be a
joke for you if you literally have
everyone saying yes what what do you
think about that the fact that like when
I say it goes from my saying to a
catchphrase like I think there's like a
difference there like I can say yo
wassup or whatever like all I want and
that can be my saying you say son and
now now a character that is based on you
says son and it's like it's gone from
you to like a whole separate thing yeah
what do you think about that
it's weird I guess I've always
questioned it within myself why do I say
sons walk at the end of the day it's
like that's why it makes people happy
you know like I love when you guys light
up when I say it so yeah I keep doing it
it makes people I don't know like I'm
all about bringing joy even even though
it's you know it's about finding those
things and I think for me it's just like
I in
joy people when people smile about it
dude you're gonna have a two-year-old
daughter who's a son like can girls be
some the all source everyone's a sudden
under the Sun is it weird is it weird to
see people punch in your head oh dude
I've seen some weird videos of murdered
yeah there's plenty look it's just like
there's random like it's like that's it
or like alright today it's like
excessive today I'm gonna murder this
yeah 13 times these guys is so I think
that would be pretty I think it would
feel very weird if I didn't already like
die in every short film that I've ever
done like everything you wear the Sean
Bean little shotgun the Sean D in this
generation yes all right
no I think that's why I literally I
could put together a death real fast and
I could I put together like good acting
moments for myself what's the weirdest
death you've ever had to do on screen
any weird ones like oh I mean falling
that that lava scene still they had to
steal that from from clothes by the way
that game shows oh it's not good it's
all set up it's all sorry it seemed like
a real idea is its it's rough the
execution is they stole it I mean dude I
mean obviously the floor is lava has
been around for a while yeah it's a
hundred and twenty something now dude
that death dude the it's like alright
hip-hip-hooray are they and then he's
like alright here we go
and then you just dive for it you
continue as a character in the story is
this like a human body log yeah I think
that sums you up son as sons you have
helped it out and you know even in
I mean might as well mines will serve to
save your life so back to bone works how
much like was that an intensive process
to like the motion capture and like
voiceovers it was honestly like it
wasn't I think we spent like three weeks
on it but it was mostly just yes um
mm-hmm mainly yeah no it was just they I
mean was super quick everybody over they
were super talented and they just did
you know 3d scans did that and I did I
didn't do any I did a few motion capture
stuff but was basically all voice you
know they basically had it all laid out
hits and grunts and exertions and it's
kind of weird I gotta be honest like we
would be Brett and I would be hanging
out playing guitar at home right and I'd
be like all right I'm gonna go play bone
works I'd go in and then I'd be and
Brett skin like it's like you're saying
like like scars and [ __ ] over there and
score on there I'm like in the other
room of my apartment
playing as my roommate one of those like
okay this is like a weird future moment
right now like I don't know man it's
it's super cool to see that people are
having fun I'm so thankful that people
are enjoying it too like that's the
biggest thing like I said safe I think
my whole mission with everything if just
one person enjoys anything that I do
it's it's it's so humbling and I'm just
thankful that you know I have good
people around me and then people who
actually yeah who care what no it's cool
cut to the pen all right well we got
tiny guns three on the docket at some
point here so maybe you can maybe you
could reprise for us as the PD is the
kingpin no I got put into a black back
of the police Corps Oh
yeah he's not dead not dead you're alive
let me know want to know have a hair out
for just for you okay well yeah I mean
you know maybe the kingpin cut his hair
I don't know that doesn't matter
maybe he grew it longer the last was
good too I love the second one that was
so intense
yeah then yeah because yeah I don't
think some people got that it was a
parody of like war movies some people
are like very offended by it but I had a
great time I thought it was oh yeah I
thought it was wonderful but I'm biased
obviously I mean no no that's hilarious
we worked hard on it yeah a good time so
let's do another one let's do a I'm down
to do it all right you heard it here
first on the corridor is there's many
more sons yeah dude it's been so uh so
good just getting to know the real Brett
driver not that we've ever had a deep
conversation ever no lies before but hey
man it was a good yeah thanks for coming
on buddy and yeah let us know when
season 3 of final space is coming out
and what else you're working on for sure
so I definitely will
yeah I got some few things coming up
I'll keep you guys posted go baloney to
Tony baloney - all right cool thanks man
thank you son appreciate ya appreciate
you come back sometime Brett I will
select some tumblr here right now I'm
hearing yeah
see you guys don't leave season